at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal
[Music]
books i've loved on the tim ferriss show
is exclusively brought to you by
audible there couldn't be a better
sponsor for this series my dear
listeners and readers
i have used audible for so many years as
long as i can remember i love it
audible has the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet i listen when
i'm taking walks
i listen while i'm cooking i listen
whenever i can
and if you're looking for a place to
start i can recommend three of my
favorites
the first is the tao of seneca
by seneca if you want to hear my
favorite letters of all time
touches on stoic philosophy calmness
under duress
etc the next is the graveyard book by
neil
gaiman g-a-i-m-a-n one of my favorites
even if you're a non-fiction
purist this is the fiction book that you
need to listen to
neil also has perhaps the most calming
voice of all time
and third greg mcewen's essentialism
subtitled the disciplined pursuit of
less this is one of my favorite books
the past few years combines
very well with the 80 20 principle but
more on audible
every month audible members get one
credit for any audio book on the site
plus a choice of multiple audible
originals from a rotating selection they
also get access to daily news digests
from the likes of the new york times
wall street journal and the washington
post
as well as guided meditation programs
and here are some other amazing audible
features and i use a bunch of these you
can download titles and listen offline
anytime
anywhere i use this feature
even when i could get access i'll put my
phone on say airplane mode
because i don't want to get bothered
with notifications and i'm taking a walk
to clear my head
and you can listen to your titles
offline in a case like that or on a
plane or whatever obviously i'm not
flying much these days
the app is free and can be installed on
all smartphones and tablets you can
listen across devices without losing
your spot
and whispersync is another feature i use
quite a lot i love reading my kindle in
bed for instance
then picking up at the same exact spot
where i left off when i go walking and
listening the next day
kindle and audio versions can be synced
up automatically it's just amazing
and if you can't decide what to listen
to don't sweat it you don't have to rush
you can keep your credits for up to a
year and use them
for instance to binge on a whole series
if you like audible offers just about
everything podcasts
guided wellness programs theatrical
performances a-list comedy and audible
originals you won't find
anywhere else and right now audible is
offering you guys
that's tim ferriss show listeners a free
audio book with a
30-day trial membership and
again my list if you want to check them
out the tao of seneca
the graveyard book essentialism those
are just three there's so many good ones
out there
just go to audible.com tim
and browse the unmatched selection of
audio programs
then download your free title and start
listening it's that easy let's check it
out go to audible.com
tim or text tim tim to
500 500 to get started today check it
out
audible.com tim
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is usually my job to sit down
with world-class performers of all
different types
startup founders investors chess
champions olympic athletes you name it
to tease out the habits that you can
apply in your own lives
this episode however is an experiment
and part of a short form series that i'm
doing
simply called books i've loved i've
invited some amazing past
guests close friends and new faces to
share their favorite books
describe their favorite books the books
that have influenced them changed them
transform them for the better and i hope
you pick up one or two
new mentors in the form of books from
this new series and apply the lessons in
your own life
i had a lot of fun putting this together
inviting these people to participate
and have learned so so much myself i
hope that is also the case for you
please enjoy
thanks tim for having me back to talk
about some of my favorite books
and i wanted to do something different
today which is i wanted to recommend
some books that
i've never recommended before on this
podcast
and that i haven't heard other people
recommending things that people may not
know about i want to turn people on to
some
new stuff that's like so central to me
so my criteria were
what are the books where i've underlined
the most amount of things
some of these books that i'm going to
recommend i literally have underlining
or
marks on every single page and i have a
kind of involved system i use to
markup books depending on the residence
of the idea and different things going
on in the book
the second thing is brought together
these books sort of
encompass like the body of
what i think right now the kinds of
things that i write about and post on
instagram
and teach and coach and have had so much
value in my life and change them and i'm
going to walk you into them
from let's say the simplest book to the
most complex
from one that's just so easy to read
to one that's almost like a textbook so
if you're into these start at the
beginning and see how far along
you get i i love all of these and
they're really
great on the path to understanding
yourself
and who you are and the obstacles that
get in your way
and where you self sabotage and your
relationships and ultimately
real freedom the first author is sherry
huber
and i wanted to tell you about her past
but i looked it up online and i can't
find anything there so i don't know if
it's public but
as a child sherry probably faced one of
the worst
traumas a young person can ever go
through
and she not only survived it she became
a buddhist monk
and if all the people i've ever met in
my life
i think she's one of the most centered
wise powerful presences i've ever been
around there's just something about her
that like in my
i would like to get to one day i really
would she writes tons of books i'd love
to read every one
and her books are very simply written
there's just distilled to
pure wisdom almost like a wise mentor is
giving you the advice
there aren't like supporting arguments
and footnotes and research studies
is just like the wisdom from high on the
mountain it's also written a unique font
where
part of the story and the power and the
impact of the words
is done through the font and style of
writing changing
as well as the illustrations by june
shiver
or it could be shiver uh the illustrator
in the book so
really look through all our books and
read anything but i'll share with you
the two that have had the biggest
impact on me actually the only two i've
read but i
do want to read the rest but i started
with a fear book
and fear book is so powerful because so
many of us
have a certain area where fear and doubt
and uncertainty get in our way
and the book walks you through the idea
of
of of how to embrace them and
move beyond them and often it's very
counterintuitive
but so true i highly recommend this for
dealing with it i want to go read you
one quote from it
i'm gonna read a couple quotes from it
and her basic idea
is that moving toward your fears and
getting past them is the path to freedom
and i love this part and her books by
the way are very short 150 pages at most
she writes if you no longer believe what
fear tells you
you will live and it will not
that is a point on the spiritual journey
that almost nobody gets past
when that terror arises when it gets
backed into a corner
and it's a matter of its survival or
yours almost nobody has a required
combination
of courage desperation willingness
to stand up to it when this force in you
that has controlled and motivated you
all your life is screaming
if you do that you're going to die very
few people
are going to say well i just need to
find out if that is true
or if that is so she writes that's why
it's so important to remember
that projection is going on what's being
screamed i'm gonna paraphrase a little
to so it kind of sinks in
what's really being screamed here is if
you stay with this fear
i will die the fear the ego will die
and that's true it will die it's life is
your death
it's death is your life
it's so good it's really about letting
go of the stuff that holds you back
you're so attached to and just isn't
serving you and is keeping you from
being free
and keeping you from being yourself and
here's one last little bit from the book
you can do right now
so good do something you fear
not to conquer the fear not to
accomplish a task
but to familiarize yourself with the
process with which fear protects itself
to demystify it and i love this i always
say i've said this podcast before
become a scientist of your own lows and
this is saying become a scientist of
fear
it's it's almost like i call it false
survival mode
there's so many things that we think are
survival threats and we treat them like
survival threats and we go
start fighting like our life is in
danger when it isn't so
it's a great demystifying empowering
book it's called the fear book
the other book of sherry hubers i
recommend and i'm pulling it out now as
we speak
is be the person you want to find
relationship and self-discovery
and the title kind of says it all and i
love this book
because it's exactly my philosophy on
relationships which is if you want to
meet
a better person then become a better
person and this is like this beautiful
book
that really elegantly sort of
weans us away from these crazy
relationship myths we have and these
expectations of other partners
and it begins by really boldly saying
that this book is about you
taking 100 responsibility for yourself
all the time and uh and i really think
if everybody could read this book and
really
live by it things would go so much
better and it's about things that we're
going to get into later and with the
next set of books
about how much of our childhood sort of
stories we end up playing out on our
partner and then again i'm just going to
read one part then we'll move on
i mean this book is so good that instead
of underlining lines i've literally like
marked entire pages so these are two of
the pages and again it flies by such a
short book
the sad strange unfortunate
dysfunctional part
of life by the way so i'm going to read
this part i'm going to paraphrase a
couple bits just so it makes sense out
of context
the sad strange unfortunate
dysfunctional part of life
is that as adults most of us are still
trying to survive
childhood so i have become the person i
believed as a child
i needed to become in order to make it
through adulthood
now i'm an adult in an intimate
relationship and i'm suffering
this is traumatic i have picked
consciously or not
someone who's going to relive parts of
my childhood with me who's going to play
the parts opposite me someone else did
back then
i'm going to suffer in the same way i
did as a child and i'm going to use
the same survival mechanisms and right
there
is literally it doesn't matter what
recurring problem you're having in a
relationship
that is the reason why and this book
gets you past them
i love it highly recommend it next
author so we're going to move sort of
one level up
on i don't want to say like difficult to
read or
advancement of concepts but also very
very accessible books
thereby p a melody i'm going to
recommend two books and we'll start with
facing codependence
and codependence is a word that's used a
lot but really rarely understood and
this book isn't just about relationships
for me
what it is is it presents a model of
trauma that to me
has been key to understanding my life
and to helping others
and just really life-changing and here's
what's fascinating about pm melody
she doesn't do ted talks at least as far
as i know
she doesn't have a big social media
presence if one at all she doesn't even
have a wikipedia injury
she was i believe a nurse at a inpatient
sort of rehab facility called the
meadows and started to develop her own
system based on a number of different
therapies and tools and it's really
powerful if i was to say hey if you
really want to change
what a modality even i hate that word
what modality should you
should you follow i'd say check into pm
melody's work
uh what's called pit post-induction
therapy i think that's what it's called
what it stands for but her whole idea is
your childhood is a hypnotic induction
you're being sort of indoctrinated it's
like a cult and
you're then to be unbrainwashed and
unhypnotized is start living your true
and free life
what a elegant idea the great part about
facing codependence besides is
exploration of what codependence is why
it happens how it happens
the signs the patterns there's also a
breakdown in the end of how she defines
trauma
and it's a way to sort of self-diagnose
trauma and i'm just going to check out
the contents right here
to me as a new parent it's also a
parenting book she talks about the
nature of a child how a child
has these rights and i've thought about
it with my child as i've raised them to
be spontaneous
to be protected to be and i love this
line perfectly and perfect
in other words some parents expect their
child to be perfect and that's sort of a
form of trauma when they're
not allowed to make mistakes or learn
their mistakes or do things that are
sort of
age-appropriate and then she talks about
abuse generational abuse and then breaks
down
trauma to these different categories of
physical abuse sexual abuse emotional
abuse
intellectual abuse spiritual abuse and
the main thing about these is it sounds
obvious
when you read it she defines abuses
anytime a child has a dependency need
that's not met
that creates abuse so a quick example of
spiritual abuse i see many with it
is when a parent has to always be right
the parent's always right they can never
be wrong they can never be corrected
and she sees that as a form of spiritual
abuse because
the parents playing god the parent
becomes the child's higher power and it
creates such a deep
insecurity on the part of the child in
terms of their reality in fact i find
these people
often resistant to work with because
they feel like to say anything negative
about their parents is like blaspheming
god it's fascinating so i highly
recommend it
the second book to read next and this
one is more about relationships but
i love it definitely something that's
quite a lot of value in my life in terms
of breaking some patterns
is called facing love addiction and it's
really
about the love addict and the love
avoidance
and this is probably like probably 75
of relationships to some degree i'm just
throwing that out ballpark
but what happens is one person in a
relationship is more needy
and one person is uh more
resentful and uh it doesn't begin that
way it begins in
this flowering of love and projection
and then
eventually this pattern plays out where
one person needs more
and the other person wants to give less
and less the other person gives the more
the other person needs and
there's this neediness resentment
pattern that eventually plays out and
blows up in negative ways often
sometimes when i know people who
have been their partners but have an
affair for a long time and they never
saw it
they're often in the haze of love
addiction where they're holding on to
this fantasy
it's a powerful book i love these both
really read these
multiple times and you'll have an
understanding of
the matrix of how relationships work
that's p melody
facing codependence and facing love
addiction
so the next book is not for everyone but
it's for a certain percentage
of people here i'm among its uh
target audience and i didn't think i was
amongst its target audience when i first
heard about it it's called silently
seduced it's by kenneth adams
and it's related to the pee melody books
i mentioned earlier and specifically for
those who've experienced enmeshment
enmeshment is not a word that's often
used so i'm going to explain it super
quickly
it's the opposite of abandonment so
abandonment as we all know is a parent
is somehow not meeting a child's needs
whether emotional
physical protection being absent
whatever it may be
enmeshment is when a child is meeting a
parent's needs
and and we don't talk about it because
abandonment
is disempowering you feel disempowered
helpless vulnerable
no one there enmeshment is falsely
empowering
you feel as a child like you have power
because you're there for your parent
a parent who lives for a child who needs
the child's accomplishments to make up
for their own accomplishments
who has a parent with tons of anxiety
needs to over control the child
a parent who's lonely or has a bad
marriage or is going through a divorce
and is using the child
for their own narcissistic reasons or to
get back at the parent
or just because they have nobody to talk
to there's so many ways
that a measurement works and here's
here's a little rule of thumb that
abandonment you feel bad about yourself
with enmeshment it's generally when you
feel sorry for the parent
so if you ever there's a moment where
you felt sad or sorry if you're a parent
that probably wasn't measurement going
on i remember interviewing jay leno
and talking about comedy and he became a
comedian because his mom was depressed
and he was always trying to cheer her up
that's a measurement
and silently seduced deals with a form
of investment that they call
shockingly emotional incest i remember
when my book the truth came out i
actually wrote an editorial from new
york times on emotional incest and
it wasn't printed it's such a shocking
term it shocked me when it was used to
diagnose me but what it is is it's when
a child is used not sexually by the
parent when a child is used
emotionally by the parent becomes an
emotional partner to them
and often it's a parent who's in a
troubled relationship who makes a child
their emotional partner
as my mom 100 did with me she'd sit
there in my room and
talk to my father and remember she
actually said neil
never grow up to make anyone as
miserable as your father makes me
which really really uh uh
messed up my relationship for a while if
i felt like somebody was sad or wasn't
wasn't happy i would just
sort of end the relationship so what
happens with people who are enmeshed
is they want love they want
relationships then they get in a
relationship and they feel suffocated
they feel trapped and they sabotage it
or want to get out of it somehow it's
this crazy intimacy attraction and
avoidance pattern usually
and it's a great book about it it walks
you through it
explains the cases and then gives you
steps to break the pattern so highly
recommended silently seduced
by kenneth adams if this is appropriate
to you or someone you've dated in the
past or someone you care about
it's a good gift i've definitely given
at least 100 of these away
i love this next author and i'm just
gonna start with this quote
he meaning the type of men he's talking
about
will believe that his masculinity is
proved by betting women
driving a high-powered car or making
lots of money
underneath he knows the truth of course
and he is desperately afraid of being
found out
he believes himself an imposter in the
company of men
and in this era in our society when
we're trying to
sort of look at the roles
men play and the mass they wear to have
a sort of better healthier society
i highly recommend this book it's
another one that i've given
this at this point probably like more
than 100 copies away
it's called under saturn shadow the
wounding and healing of men
by james hollis and james hollis is a
jungian
psychoanalyst an amazing author i
actually love this book so much i hadn't
been my therapist for a while and was
literally like taking a college class
it's so good it's not the easiest book
to make it through
but it's so dense with meaning with
historical example
with amazing quotes and it really looks
at a deep mythical
psychological level at the struggles
that the modern sort of man
faces and attempts to put a framework
around it that's so
wonderfully full of wisdom and i really
don't see this sort of
addressed a lot in a helpful useful
non-shaming uh self-understanding way
i was looking for another quote but i
stumbled across this i literally have
something underlined on every page
what father cannot access in himself
cannot be passed on to his son
such a good thing to think about it for
the parents out there like myself
so good i'm just gonna read a little
part i'm literally just turning to a
random page there's so much in here
it's just worth reading all the time he
writes as joseph campbell expressed it
one can spend one's whole life climbing
the ladder only to realize
that it's been placed against the wrong
wall for men to begin the process of
healing
they must first risk being honest with
themselves allowing the feelings they
think they can't afford
they must admit they're not happy in
spite of what they've achieved
they must admit they do not know who
they are or what they must do to save
themselves
they must overcome the fear that blocks
such thinking the fear that they will
have to change their lives
if the emotional cat is let out of the
bag
and ultimately it's a book about sort of
self-examination and making sure you're
not just running on these preset tracks
that the culture has
given you and really living out what's
important to you or as holla says it
and i'll end the description of the book
with this the crux of the middle passage
is the requirement that a man whatever
his age or station
pull out of his reflexive behaviors and
attitudes radically re-examine his life
at risk living out the thunderous
imperatives of his soul
so good highly recommended so one of
james hollis central ideas is we have
these two
that we have these two fantastic quests
we go on in our lives
one is the fantasy of immortality and
the other one is the fantasy of the
magical other
and the latter is the heart of his other
book that i love which is the eden
project
and let me get the subtitle here the
eden project
in search of the magical other uh kind
of like the sherry huber book
he just cuts the core of it i'm gonna
look right now one of my favorite quotes
from it it's so good
it's so good being in an intimate
relationship
is a bit like asking someone to join
hands with us but only after walking
across a field
in which we have planted minds and
another great quote and i think this
just captures the book
he writes the best thing we can do for
our relationships with others
is to render our relationship to
ourselves more conscious
this is not a narcissistic activity in
fact
it will prove to be the most loving
thing we can do for the other
the greatest gift to others is our own
best selves
thus paradoxically if we are to serve
relationship well
we are obliged to affirm our individual
journey
it's so good and yes it's just like the
wisdom of the sherry huber book i want
to love about all these books
whether it's sort of pee a melody coming
from inpatient addiction rehab
or it's james hollis coming from jung
or sherry huber coming from buddhism
it's the exact same wisdom so if you
read all these books
if you put them all together they're all
telling the same thing
so go do it hey guys this is tim again
just a few more things before you take
off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
four hourworkweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and you will
get the very next one
and if you sign up i hope you enjoy